depuis le jour de sitôt sur la maladie
la bonne grosse maladie écoute et qu'on
est malade qu'est ce qu'on fait on joue
un jeu qui fait extrêmement rageant
l'avait déjà fait sur ce point m x cse à
de fer plateforme ère mais aujourd'hui
je veux qu'on aille au bout de tous les
niveaux de ce jeu et une autre qui la
croyait on va y arriver croyez moi à le
piège classique on connaît bien elle va
faire parler note ce qui a pu teint
aujourd'hui on va faire pas les notes
style de vétérans des joueurs agent à ça
tu ça ok ok alors mais il faut
s'habituer à l'environnement s'adapter
tel un caméléon est ensuite ya plus de
problème
ça dégage ça c'est des gages se
dégagerait il ya plus de problème là ah
mais je vais claque avec mon siège quoi
profil à chaque fois chaque voyage
l'avocat c'est vous remarquerez j'ai de
bonnes idées pour l'avoir encore plus ça
a cassé
c'est comme ça qu'on sonne ça c'est
comme ça qu'on a maintenant j'en ferai
plus jamais de trop mal ce jeu allez-y
zizi easy jet désir tient à je suis une
mèche une énorme merde pas les papilles
pamiers n'a pas pas pas allé du mot
terminé qu'est ce tu vas y mon gars
c'est comme ça qu'on fait au fait que
comme ça qu'on joue jouait le mail
suivant nickel faut attendre au wex te
plaît toutes les stratégies qu'on peut
imaginer le mec les contre quoi va chier
attention il ya une courants d'air de
skill dans la pièce
c'est en plus certains c'est tellement
frustrant d'avoir envie de crier de
hurler sur des espoirs et ça n est pas
pourquoi vous une voix de kung fu passer
au dessus de ce bloc là en fait je pense
c'est maintenant la à oued et battante
dénommé mec à moi c'est ce qu'ont à
l'eau ce qui se passe dans ce vidéo à la
et tous les gens ils vont dire à fin mai
juste à faire ça non non non non non non
non voilà au revoir jean michel conques
lie un piège à rien je le sens croyez
moi j'en mets d'égout dans monde et
assemble hall alors sorti les pièges
grâce à ces gouttes santé et pièges mais
c'est face à blake m'a abordé louvel
type et là oh la vache et gadret du
premier coup du premier coup voilà les
helvètes qui comprend pas qu'il est nul
à chier qui fait que de la merde que
tout le monde vu dans les gradins voilà
allez ciao styliste je peux rebondir sur
la tête des ennemis of may foot de gia
j'ai fait confiance en le move le plus
d'émules d'europe
ça s'est passé à tapas mois l'équipe qui
me pierre a fait prendre un strip skill
une pastille qui donne un max de ce
qu'ils donnent elles doivent pas trop du
bourg regardez un deux trois c'est pas
normal
il ya des pièces qui doivent être dur
c'est ça je beurre aussi couramment dans
cette vidéo là et c'est la weed trouve
assez ce jeu beaucoup trop sympec ah ah
ah non mais attends plus de pièges au
mètre carré se te plaît quoi
à adado bol commettre une gaffe souhaité
tout petit comme ça c'est très arrogant
et impolie monsieur non aux adjoints
doit toutefois nadu au programme des
scènes obstiné par ce jeu je ne pense
qu'à gagner à réussir quelque chose dans
ma vie maintenant le aller j'avais
anticipé
ça c'est le street style ça que tu vas
faire bien que de mourir et de mourir
immédiatement clôturé à paris il ya un
problème de synchronisation dans mon
cerveau a à l'heure actuelle
ok on est bon mais bon les bons mais bon
faut plus réfléchir quand tu fais cette
phase-là du jeu quand tu paies un sudoku
mais sous débit on est bondée vendée bon
vous réfléchi par an on est bien là on
est bien là on à l'abri là on réfléchit
maintenant à voir avec tout un message
juste que des bugs cerveau mais bon rien
à les suivants l'arbre final on finit le
jeu on finit le jeu il ya aucun problème
à équipe cachée j'aime pas fait exprès à
cucq cacher j'ai pas fait exprès j'avais
des frissons tellement ça me manque
lâche l'homme viril level maximum mais
bon les mounir oui oh oui oh oui ce
style au nom d'êta
bon allez on y va on y va changer de
coin a put un cheval barbe du bien
visible
un cobra se juin de mauvaise et plus
rien de rien mais nathan ya pas de kyoto
montage là et baird
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok bad blood
voilà je vais chanter du taylor swift
maintenant nous gagnons bas belote
baglan
ah mais qui a quand même du bien visible
à lui ensuite tu ne passes pas invisible
à lhassa pas sauvegardé attention y'a
pas de cut il s'élance vers ce cube il
passe le cube sans difficulté dans la
merde cette fois c'est bon regardez je
blague pas attention attention à c'était
une blague à la bonne boutade on n'avait
pas vu arriver celle-là rompu vrai le
caillou ni trop près de nous il met la
pression
les habitants se plaît pour qu'on puisse
d'essai c'est un coup là voilà voilà peu
grosse merde là on est soufflé
j'aimerais un peu de chance dans la
salle j'ai un petit on doit ça puisque
là il ya un homme qui est ce qu'on
semble ok théodore au troisième rang tu
vas parler c'est pour ça que ça m'a
déconcentré que j'ai perdu d'accord
alors maintenant tu vas fermer sa as
j'aimerais muté ça là où elle arrivée là
on va y aller vous allez voir des lois
[Musique]
ok on reprend alors fait la deuxième
partie de la poursuite infernale du
camion à ce jeu all apache va vite aller
ft le troisième le 3e lucas j'ai retenu
le troisième est jouée en plein dessus
au le co jeudi quand j'aurai 40 ans et
j'aurai un fils faudra surtout pas
qu'ils viennent me demander quelque
chose quand je joue à ce jeu je pourrais
lui couper la tête ont deux fois là sauf
quand je suis dans le bella il peut
venir donc tout ce qu'il veut jouer ça
c'est fait le mail suivant alors qu'est
ce que c'est que ces histoires il et
easy équipe qui vole on n'y prête pas
attention là pas de problème c'est nul
ça fait peur à personne puisqu'il tous
pas seulement voilà on est autant et
arrogant et ça marche je m'envolais sec
voilà je mal foutu je les touche et ça a
marché dessus bord au alors ça c'est un
truc de fdp ça allez ciao ciao ciao bomb
et la joie éternelle par là bas et ben
on va y aller et mourir comme des
grosses j'ai peur ça passe mais c'est
tellement facile
c'est tellement simple ce jeu ce jeux à
butin j'essaie de santé il est pas
trouvée dans la feinte
attention attention moi que je regardais
ya plus de que de l'attention c'est la
magie ce spectacle c'est la magie du
montage
steve ajusteur celano magie du montage
ne va pas de montage regardez moi ça
c'est fait je suis comme tout se joue
mais nord a le petit dernier ajuste hier
la news - gâchait pas je pouvais faire
ça n'était pas dans un bon jour des
capacités avant cette vidéo maintenant
ça les a baptisés noisette ou d'aller
voir une oie bardon anna petit poney au
ski vinh extremis il y avait même les
orteils d'envié
et leïla va aux eaux alors revenir en
arrière là à les adapter aux hourras je
me sens tellement mieux ma vie est
tellement bien depuis j'ai assez à fin
c'est la fin mais c'est un jeu pour les
offres mais c'est la rage pour les
enfants on l'a fait en 35 minutes regard
2 voilà c'est marquer la rentrée six
minutes 30
voilà tu aimes les pas faire la focus le
conte voilà c'était ma vie en ce 30
septembre avec la bonne maladie
eh bien écoutez je pars sur une sieste a
plus sa permanence des votes cette vidéo
ça décape et j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la
vidéo comme d'habitude on se retrouve
très bientôt dans une prochaine et je
trouve qu'on a pas si je joue un peu
trop facilement
c'était la facilité taille seulement
voilà même peut-être que jumbo quoi à
tomber dans une nouvelle vidéo portez
vous bien je trouve pis
[Musique]